[музика]
їх що ви , them and she wore там видав
животи
навчання до 12 руки в учити школі я куми
моєму сьогодні я вигляд винен і в роті і
ніхто не збирається цугару б ти там у
що на мені потрібно клімат йдуть від
килимок дітей у такі знання та школі
лиж анапи х і знанням і і я ккд куди
забирає здоров'я на тому місці у новій
школі де засовуватимуть за участю
це так і компетентного навчання моєму
сама втече відривалися на вч вони там у
що організувати проектну роботу
у команді та забезпечать приватний
модерна есмь issues with і можна лише і
видав жують she годину на спинку ванні з
дітьми там вже і значить але просиш і
кародж і прийти і розповісти і я кусь
інформатику путін guide & match with
varied та інша справа колеги ти
експериментальним шляхом доходять до
пивних виставки іншу
історію влас не проекти ми заслужили і
натще дати нашим дітям such as ну а
свиту то свиту я коли сенс і висимо but
i успішними так 12 рік навчання потребую
інвестиції з бюджету України там
недавно що на території Європи
два на чотири чко за вишилась у трьох
околицях в Росії та Білорусії та Україні
олег calendar реформи так і що ми dota
краще asus можемо вона копається ти такий
ресурс краще спочатку power таїмося до
структури 12 річкові школи з початкова 4
річковий школа вона травня собі 2 цикл цьому
що століття вага кути вас тяги струм pedrollo
класу навіть видозмінюється
вид tracker 4 класу вид по видно буду
побуду ванної процес навчання з місця
світи далі д базово середня школа
ми будемо називати
їм нас
його на бути зупинить знову уроки
профіль на середню школу другі руки та
весь профіль на середнього світу ми можемо
уступу ватою як нерозлучним з перебуванням
у ліцеях так і запити сильні
перебуванням управ та сильних ліцеях та
профі сильних коледжах
[музика]